Hi.
So welcome back to human emotion.
Say we're going to continue to talk about the ways in which emotion shape our
judgements and decisions when it comes to money.
So again,
we're going to be trying to pick up this question of in what way does our wallet
reflect our feelings?
And also looking at the other direction of a what way do our emotions actually
shape the kinds of economic decisions that we make,
how we spend our money,
whether or not to save our money,
should we donate to charity?
And precisely how should we try to save for our longterm future?
And really what does emotion have anything to do with these questions?
So this will be our second module looking at judgment and decision making.
And today we'll be talking about emotion and spending.
So here we'll be looking at this question.
As you can see here,
can feelings actually shape our spending?
So this is a roadmap that will take us through this question.
We'll start by looking at emotion and consumption.
So in what way does emotion shape the kinds of things that we consume in terms
of,
you know,
what we buy and how we spend them.
We'll look at this field of neuroeconomics of emotion,
a really novel interdisciplinary field that tries to integrate across
psychology,
economics and neuroscience to understand what is the brain basis.
You know,
the ways in which we spend our money and think about our money.
Then we'll conclude with our takeaway questions and expert interview.
So let's start with this topic of emotion and consumption and thinking precisely
how does emotion shaped the way that we spend our money and consume products in
the world around us.
So we all know that emotions play some role and how we buy things and what we
buy.
You can see advertisements here that really tried to provoke us to elicit
feelings maybe of desire or have pride and status.
And in some way it seems that the very ads that we see,
you know,
just everywhere in our everyday life in some ways are picking up on emotions.
And those emotions in some way may be shaping the kinds of things we want.
Whether it's a,
you know,
diamond set,
it's cell phone or a really fancy car or some really cool clothes,
but really precisely how do emotions shape our behavior patterns of,
you know,
financial consumption.
I think it's first important to start with this I question of what do we mean by
consumption in the first place.
So here I'm just going to walk through a very basic definition.
So consumption is the process in which goods and services are bought and used to
serve people's wants,
which are called luxuries as well as their needs or necessities.
Necessities are goods and services for which a demand is insensitive to changes
in consumer income such as medicine,
whereas luxuries by contrast,
our goods and services for which demand is sensitive to changes in consumer
income.
So things like jewelry or fancy clothing or a fancy car.
So most consumption,
interestingly the United States as the consumption of luxuries instead of
necessities.
So for example,
one of the kinds of luxuries you often spend our money on that's um,
an everyday kind of luxury is spending money on movies.
And I think one of the most perplexing questions here,
and we think about how we spend our money on this kind of luxury is why do we
spend money to feel negative?
Why do we pay to watch horror films like the grudge or saw?
You can think of many others that actually make us feel feelings of fear or
disgust.
So this has been a really perplexing question in this field for some time now,
right?
Because consumer research should assume that as human beings we would pursue
pleasure and try to avoid pain.
So then why would so many people enjoy and pay money to be terrified?
We have giant industries devoted to,
you know,
horror films.
And why do other people seem to dislike horror films and wouldn't go even if
someone paid them to go.
So what is this relationship between spending money and eliciting negative
emotions?
So some colleagues did a study to really try to answer this at least as a first
pass,
as to why do we consume negative emotions?
So in this study they had participants in two groups.
They had participants who enjoy horror films or dislike horror films.
And maybe you can think of yourself in which category you fall into,
um,
whether you like horror films or you'd rather kind of stay away from them.
And then the method that they employed here with these two groups of people is
they had them rate their emotional states before and after watching a very
horrific movie clip.
And here's what they found.
So the results suggest that participants who enjoyed horror films experienced
the same increase in negative emotion as those who dislike horror films.
So it's pretty wild,
right?
People who do and do not like horror films both feel the same degree of negative
emotionality and the same intensity of that experience when they watch these
films.
But here's the crucial difference.
They also experienced increases and positive emotion.
So participants who don't like horror films don't experience positive emotion,
but those who do also experience positive emotion.
So what the authors tried to propose here is that this co-occurrence of both
positive and negative emotions,
seeing bumps up in both is what makes horror movies particularly pleasurable for
those people who seek them out.
It's almost like you're amping up your emotional system in both the positive and
negative valence direction.
And that's what motivates people to go out and seek some of these horror films.
And it's those people who have the absence of positive emotion that are going to
be less likely to spend money consuming negative emotions.
Okay,
so that's about consuming negative emotions.
What about spending money as an,
in terms of how it relates to our happiness?
Do we think money can buy happiness?
Traditionally?
You know,
we know this expression that we say to ourselves and that we hear,
you know,
in the media that money really can't buy happiness.
And this has been sort of the long prevailing conception for many years until
very recently when two colleagues of mine,
uh,
Elizabeth Dunn and Michael Norton did a groundbreaking study finding that there
are actually some ways in which money can buy happiness.
They found though that it's when you spend money on other people.
So they found that spending money on others promotes happiness.
And particularly if you look at the abstract here,
I'll read it with you.
They say,
although much research has examined the effect of income on happiness,
we suggest that how people spend their money may be at least as important as how
much money they earn.
So they height.
We hypothesize that spending money on other people may have a more positive
impact on happiness than actually spending money on oneself providing converging
evidence.
For this hypothesis,
we found that spending money of one's income on others predicted greater
happiness,
both cross-sectionally in a nationally representative survey study and
longitudinally in a field study of windfall spending.
And finally participants who were randomly assigned to spend money on others
experience greater happiness than those assigned to spend money on themselves.
Now these findings have gained widespread attention and really may suggest why
buying presence rather people are donating to charity make us feel so good.
And as a result of this research,
both Michael Norton and Liz Dunn have given a lot of talks in the public media
and now have a book that has just come out called happy money.
The science of spark smarter spending.
And here what it explains his ways in which perhaps you can get more happiness
for your money by following what they outline is five core principles from
choosing experiences over stuff,
to spending money on others.
And in these five principles outlined in their book,
they can be used not only by individuals,
but perhaps also had a bigger group level by companies who are perhaps going to
try to seek to create happier employees and provide happier products to their
customers.
So both I'm done and Norton really show how companies from Google to Pepsi have
put these ideas into action.
So if you're interested in really learning about this really groundbreaking new
field of how money might actually promote happiness,
if you spend it on others and you spend in certain ways,
I highly recommend checking out their book happy money.
So now we're going to turn to a different side of thinking about emotion
consumerism.
And here what we're going to look at is this idea of consumer ad evaluation.
So how emotions shaped the way that we influence advertisements around us.
We all see commercials and everyday life and precisely in what way does our
current mood state shaped the way that we perceive that Ad.
So here's a study that was done by Goran and colleagues and it went is followed.
So participants listen to music.
Um,
they are randomly assigned to either listen to pleasant,
upbeat music or more unpleasant music.
And then they saw a series of advertisements.
One was of a man and woman walking in the distance that was relatively
ambiguous.
Um,
this is the one on the right,
you can see two people walking in the distance and the other on the left was a
advertisement of a really happy family spending time together.
That is,
has a very clear positive tone.
So again,
they saw ads that either had a more ambiguous tone or one that had a clear,
positive social tone.
They were then asked to provide their evaluations of the ad.
So examples of the questions they were asked is I like the ad or the ad is good
or bad.
Right.
And what they found in their study is that participants in the pleasant music
condition reported a rating.
The add more favorably compared to the unpleasant music condition.
Right.
And this was interesting because this was really pronounced for the ad that had
a more ambiguous tone.
But when the ad had a very,
very clear positive tone,
the emotional elicitation had no influence on how people evaluated the ad.
So it seems to be that our emotional states may shape how we evaluate an ad and
how,
you know,
positively we perceive it when the ad is relatively neutral or ambiguous in
tone.
Okay.
Here's another very interesting study that looks at how emotions shape the way
that we think about advertisements that we're bombarded with all the time.
So this was a study looking at empathy versus pride in beer ads,
right?
So we see beer ads all the time.
And in what way can emotions of empathy and bright up anything to do with
thinking about buying beer?
Right?
So what they did is they had participants,
either American participants coming from more individualistic cultures or
Chinese participants coming from more tradition collectivistic cultures.
And what they did is they expose students to beer ads that either evoked
feelings of pride or evoke feelings of empathy.
So an example here of the pride beer ad is,
um,
you know,
aceing the last exam,
winning the big race,
receiving a deserved recognition and having the Ohio,
you know,
flag beer and celebrating life's accomplishments,
right?
So beer really being advertised in this very pride eliciting context.
This is contrasted with the empathy condition where,
you know,
they're trying to sell beer,
but it's in a scene if you know,
you're reminiscing with old friends,
enjoying time together with family and relaxing with best friends.
And again,
you see the Ohio flag beer and it's about celebrate braiding relationships that
matter the most.
So again,
pride,
the theme they're trying to evoke in the beer ad is celebrating life's
accomplishments or as an empathy.
It's about celebrating relationships that mattered the most.
And here's their findings that I find really,
really interesting.
Okay.
So just to point out what you have is the individualist culture here on the
right and the collected this culture here on the left and you have here other
focused emotion,
empathy and ego focused,
what they call it,
ego focused emotion or pride.
And look what you're seeing.
This is in some ways really surprising.
So what you're seeing is that higher values on the scale and indicated greater
liking a of the advertisement and the brand.
So what you see is that in collectivistic cultures on the left seemed to
actually like the pride focused add more than the empathy focused ad.
And you see an interaction here whereby the individualistic culture by contrast
seems to report more favorable liking attitudes towards the empathy or other
focus beer ad as opposed to the individual store pride ad.
So this is surprising because you might've hypothesize that the Chinese are more
collectivistic cultures would report a more favorable attitudes towards the
empathy related add.
One that's more consistent props with you might say,
are there cultural,
culturally embedded emotional values?
Whereas you would expect the American are more individualistic,
you know,
participants to report more favorable attitudes towards the pride.
Eliciting a ad again consistent with our cultural norms of you know,
favoring high arousal positive states that are individualistic focused.
So how do we explain this like complete reversal of the findings,
right?
So the authors argue that it's the presentation of a novel type of thought.
Something that's unexpected,
something that goes outside of your everyday sort of traditional way of thinking
about the world that underlies why ads are particularly appealing.
And I'm curious to think what you,
what you think about when you think about ads that seem appealing.
Is it really the novelty that grabs your attention,
that causes you to like them more,
something different than sort of the everyday kind of emotional experience and
culture you live in?
This suggests that perhaps yes.
That's one really important factor in determining how or why people report
favorable attitudes towards ads.
That it sort of breaks outside of their normal cultural values.
So we've talked about emotion and consumption and now I just want to turn to
this field of neuroeconomics of emotion.
So neuro economic models of decision making have traditionally emphasized the
assessment of value as a critical factor in driving choice behavior.
And so this is a newly emerging field and what it tries to do is link economic
decision making to the brain and how it functions.
And so this emerging field of neuroeconomics has highlighted the overlap between
neural systems that mediate choice and other behaviors including emotion.
So we're going to just get a preview of what this exciting field has to share
with us and what potential it has as we move forward in the field of aspect of
neuroscience and try to integrate it with how we spend our money and with you
know,
models of economic decision making.
So first,
well,
what is neuro economics in the first place?
So here I have a definition for you.
Neuro economics is an interdisciplinary research program with the goal of
building biological models of decision making within economic environments.
So here neuroeconomist asks,
how does the embodied brain enable the minder,
perhaps groups of minds to make economic decisions and being highly multiple
multimodal.
This field combines techniques from cognitive neuroscience and experimental
economics as well as an effect of science.
The course that you're taking now to observe how neural activity depends on the
economic environment and also ask questions about how the mind makes economic
decisions.
So how do we link neuro economics to emotion?
So I really liked this quote here from the New York Times that said people are
efficient,
rational beings who tires loosely act in their own self interest.
They make financial decisions based on reason,
not emotion,
and naturally most save money for that proverbial rainy day.
Right?
Well,
no,
in making financial decisions,
people are regularly influenced by gut feelings and emotional intuitions.
They cooperate with total strangers,
gambled away the family paycheck and squander their savings on investments
touted by known liars.
So what's really interesting here is that to explore decisionmaking,
researchers are scanning the brains of people as they engage in a variety of
games designed by experimental economists.
And these exercises are really intended to make people anticipate what others
will do or what other people infer from one person's own actions.
And so it's a really exciting idea where you look at the brain as this way to
compare how we evaluate objects,
people,
events and memories,
internal states,
and the perceived needs of others so that we can make choices in our everyday
life.
And so interestingly,
instead of dollars and cents,
we know that the brain relies on the firing rates of a number of
neurotransmitters,
chemicals like dopamine that transmit nerve impulses.
So we think of novelty,
money,
cocaine,
a delicious meal,
a beautiful face,
all these things that APP activate these dopaminergic circuits that we talked to
our earlier in our lectures on brain and emotion,
that signal values of reward and pleasure,
right to varying degrees.
So what you can look at is just how much people have activation in these really
emotionally salient brain regions and how that helps calibrate peoples,
you know,
emotional responses and economic decisions in everyday life.
So I'll give you an example of one kind of question that's relevant to
neuroeconomics and emotion.
And this is how much people value monetary rewards and how we process them
differently.
So this is touching on a topic that we delved into earlier in our lecture and
emotion and the brain.
So here we are distinguished in earlier lectures between the anticipation or
wanting of a reward.
And so for the dog it's a bone.
But let's imagine it's a human with you know,
a big stack of money,
um,
from the consumer Tory,
pleasure or liking of a reward.
And what we found is when we looked at anticipatory processing in the brain,
and you think of this idea of wanting money,
but this is really governed by a special system called the mesolimbic dopamine
system that includes the prefrontal Cortex,
the nucleus accumbens accumbens,
and the ventral tegmental area.
Right?
So this is interesting because it's contrast it with an entirely different set
of neural systems that are associated with the consumer,
Tory or liking of money,
right?
So sort of having it in the moment.
So liking again as this conscious awareness of pleasure and hedonic experience.
And what you find here from neuroimaging and neural recording studies is that
the liking of rewards is really governed by two different hedonic hotspots.
So you have on the left,
the nucleus accumbens hotspot,
and on the right,
the ventral pallidum hotspot,
right?
And these hedonic hotspots are crucial for how the brain not only produces
pleasurable feelings in response to food and sex and drugs,
but also for money,
right?
So there's researchers who have looked at these two different neural systems and
interestingly when they're looking at the anticipate anticipation and then
conservatory,
you know,
processing of money,
it tells us a lot about just how the brain and just how emotion plays an
important role in that process.
And here I'll just wrap up with some other questions that are commonly asked in
neuro economics and emotion.
And these are really cutting edge questions that we're just now trying to
discover the answers to.
So these include questions such as how do emotions shaped the immediate versus
delayed processing of monetary rewards?
How do emotions shape economic negotiations?
How does the brain process the experience of financial risk taking and what are
the neural systems associated with regret and gambling?
Okay,
so now we'll turn to our takeaway questions.
So here,
the first question asks,
how does emotion influence our consumption patterns?
Second,
how does emotion influence the way people evaluate consumer ads and what are
potential sources of cultural variation and collectivistic and individualistic
groups?
And finally,
what are the kinds of questions the field of neuroeconomics addresses?
Okay.
And now we'll turn to our experts in emotion interview as part of the experts in
emotion interview series.
And today in this expert interview,
we'll be speaking with doctor Brian Knutson,
who's an associate professor of psychology at Stanford University and the
director of the symbiotic project on affect of neuroscience.
And he is one of the leading figures in this area.
We'll speak with us about the field of neuro economics and emotion.
So doctor Knutson,
um,
received his bachelor degree in psychology and comparative religion from Trinity
and his phd from Stanford University after which he did postdoctoral research
and affect of neuroscience at the UCF medical school and the National Institute
of Health.
His laboratory uses multiple methods including psychometrics,
psychophysiology brain imaging and pharmacology to investigate neural mechanisms
that underlie emotional experience.
And he also explores implications of this work for clinical disorders.
Have an effect and addiction as well as for economic decision making.
Their discovery that neural activity correlates with expected value and can be
used to predict choice,
including financial risk taking and product purchases,
has helped seed new and exciting interdisciplinary fields,
including neuro economics,
neuro finance,
and neuromarketing.
Doctor Knutson has received young investigator awards from the American
Psychiatric Association,
the National Alliance for research on schizophrenia and depression,
and the Academy of Behavioral Medicine Research.
He's also a fellow of the American Psychological Society and Academy of
Behavioral Medicine Research.
His research is funded by grants from several organizations,
including the National Institutes of Health and National Science Foundation.
He's been invited to speak about his research and psychology,
psychiatry,
neuroscience,
economics,
finance,
and marketing departments around the world.
And his laboratories.
Research is regularly featured in top journals and popular media outlets.
So I now turn to our very special experts and emotion interview with Doctor
Brian Knutson.